on April 26 1913 a thirteen-year-old
girl named Mary Phagan was murdered in
Marietta Georgia soon after a Jewish
factory owner was arrested and charged
with the crime up next author Steve Oni
talks about this event in his book and
the dead shall rise the murder of Mary
Phagan and the lynching of Leo Frank he
explores the other suspects in the case
the possibility that anti-semitism
played a part in the conviction and he
argues that the case became
sensationalized because of the New York
Times the Georgia Historical Society
hosted this hour and 45 minute event
welcome everyone
Evon II I'm the author of and the dead
shall rise I'm delighted that y'all are
here both those of you at the Strand
Theatre on the historic square in
Marietta Georgia and those watching on
c-span I'm honored that the Georgia
Historical Society invited me to join
you and have stand eaten
it's senior historian as my co-host
there's really no place I'd rather be on
this summer night then in this lovely
southern town although I now live in
California I grew up in Georgia it's
wonderful being back seeing old friends
many old friends making some new ones
southerners are warm and embracing and
really the best word dear so dear the
south is a golden place yet as we all
know there is another darker south
behind locked doors in almost every
southern town something unspeakable has
been hidden nowhere is that more true
than Marietta a hundred years ago
tonight a stone's throw from where were
gathered the best men of Marietta were
putting the last touches on a bold and
damnable
they were motivated they believed by
desire for justice but nothing about the
results of their actions would be just
they would Lynch a man most likely an
innocent one they would terrify
traumatize a generation of American Jews
particularly Atlanta Jews they would sow
pain and misunderstanding across the
country these men came from Marietta's
finest families their names adorn street
signs public buildings monuments not
just in town but across Georgia their
ghosts are here tonight
I am intensely aware of that and if you
let yourselves you will be too and they
are not alone
Cobb County farmers and merchants
carried out the horrific instructions of
these were these if I close my eyes I
can see them
barreling in open-air cars through the
Georgia countryside toward the state
prison in Milledgeville also here is
Mary Phagan the 13 year old child
laborer whose brutal murder Marietta
sought to avenge here too is Tom Watson
the agrarian rebel who gave the final
fatal orders then there is Leo Frank the
Jewish industrialist convicted of
murdering little Mary Governor John
Clayton commuted Frank's death sentence
to life imprisonment setting in motion
the chain of events that would lead the
party for Marietta to abduct Frank from
the state prison drive him up the gut of
Georgia in the dead of night and lynch
him at dawn on August 17th 1915 the site
was near where fries gin road
intersects Roswell Street today it's
paved over by interstate 75 Marietta not
surprisingly has had a difficult
relationship with the legacy of Leo
Frank in Cobb County official history
Frank gets but a single dismissive
mention Frank comma non-resident but Leo
Frank will forever be a resident of
Marietta and his spirit is here too on
the hundredth anniversary of the Leo
Frank lynching
we have summoned these goes to the
Marietta square although as I thought
about what I was going to say tonight I
realized that it is they who have
summoned us and they've called us here
to do a specific job to reckon with
their deeds that's a powerful word to
reckon in my mind it conjures those Old
Testament prophets like Ezekiel and
Jeremiah who hurled jehovah's Thunder
both city Israeli Ikes the Israelites
but it also has a broaden broader and
more generous definition to consider and
that's what I hope we'll do tonight
consider the murder of Mary Phagan
consider the lynching of Leo Frank and
consider why a century later it all
still matters a couple preliminaries the
past is is different from the present as
a foreign land is from home
the people of 1915 their lives their
attitudes so dissimilar from ours
particularly about the subjects of sex
and race and the Frank case is all about
sex and race that said the issues they
faced were surprisingly similar to those
we faced and that they thought the world
was spinning out of control they no
longer knew what the future held with
them the agrarian age was
turning into the Industrial Age with us
the Industrial Age is transforming to
the Information Age the people
themselves they were exactly like us
they loved and they longed they felt
pain and joy as we delve into this
tragedy I'd like us to keep an open mind
about what Georgia was like in 1915 and
open hearts about the people who got
caught up in this affair the ghost of
Leo Frank for all wants flesh and blood
human beings and I hope we'll treat them
humanely that doesn't mean we have to
pull our punches that doesn't mean we
can't be fierce but I hope we'll be
respectful and fair the ghost of Leo
Frank have summoned us here because they
would like to be understood and I think
if we can understand them we might find
what it is that we seek and that's peace
on this summer night in this lovely
southern town in this year when the past
is suddenly no longer history in the
south when history has become front-page
news
whether it's about Charleston or ongoing
debate about Confederate iconography I
think it'd be a fine thing to have a
little understanding and a little peace
Stan thank you Steve on behalf of the
Georgia Historical Society I'd like to
welcome all of you to tonight's program
thank you for coming my name is Stan
Beaton I am the senior historian at the
Georgia Historical Society and it's my
pleasure to facilitate this discussion
tonight and to introduce our guest Steve
Oni besides being a fellow graduate at
the University of Georgia's Grady
College of Journalism and mass
communication where he is a Grady fellow
and a Nieman fellow at Harvard Steve is
what I like to call the last living
witness of the Leo Frank lynching he is
the author of course of the most
definitive account we have of this case
a book entitled and the dead shall rise
the murder of Mary Phagan and the
lynching of Leo Frank originally
published by pant
books in 2003 in researching and writing
this book over a number of years Steve
did what none of us can do now he spoke
to people who actually saw Leo Frank's
body hanging from a tree in 1915 he
talked to people who knew Mary Phagan
Leo Frank Jim Connelly and Tom Watson
the story behind the story is a
remarkable one and Steve is going to
share it with us tonight
Steve how did you get interested in the
Leo Frank case in 1984
that's right 1984 yikes I flew to
Tennessee to interview a dying patient
at the Veterans Administration Hospital
and Mountain View and this was 85
year-old Alonzo man at age 14 he'd been
Leo Frank's office boy so I got the
mountain view it was Christmastime and I
interviewed Alonzo in common room at the
hospital room filled with the dying and
the halt and the lame and he told me
this remarkable story about what he had
seen at the National pencil company on
the day Mary Phagan was murdered and he
had first told this story in fairness to
the Nashville Tennessean and they broke
the news and that led to an application
for a posthumous pardon for Leo Frank
here in Georgia but I felt the story had
never been written up in a narrative so
I pitched the idea to Esquire and as far
as I need to do a piece and so I
interviewed Alonso's spent a lot of time
looking back through trial records and
newspaper accounts and I went back to
Los Angeles and wrote my article and it
was a lengthy article as a 10,000 word
article which even for Esquire is quite
long and I turned it in they liked it
and they said we're going to hold it in
till fall until the issues are bigger
because even for Esquire that's a
lengthy story and I went on with my life
and it so happened I fell in love with
the beautiful woman and I asked her to
marry me and we set our wedding date and
a week before the wedding I got a call
from Escobar saying get ready we're
going
and I like ready and went off on my
honeymoon and where most new husbands
would take poetry or some lingerie the
proofs of my article for Esquire a
bundle of notes in a box of number two
Ticonderoga pencils and my wife has
lasting memories of me on our honeymoon
sitting and editing this piece and
educating back and forth to the editors
in New York well flash forward I write
my book it takes me 17 years 17
agonizing years and it's hard work and
I'm having to yeah thank you that's fine
I'm having to make a living during this
period stories but anyway I finish my
book and my wife hosts a little party
when I turn in the last pages of the
manuscript and we're standing on our
back porch in Los Angeles and a group of
people is surrounding us and she begins
to tell you the story
tell them the story that I just told you
and she's a good rocking chair and I'm
thinking where is she going with this
where is she going
and she told about our honeymoon and me
with my box of number-two pencils and
she said that's when I realized I had
two husbands I was the bride of Leo
Frankenstein so it was a funny line but
sobering ly true as it turned out we're
going to break this talk down into
several parts and we're going to begin
tonight the first part is going to be
we're going to talk about the murder of
Mary Phagan and then Leo Frank's trial
two-part question Steve first of all I
want you to tell us who was Mary Phagan
and then the second part of that is that
today a murder of a 13 year old girl of
course the tragic there have been
thousands of thirteen-year-old girls who
had been murdered since 1913 we're still
talking about this one why so first who
is Mary Phagan
why are we still talking about this case
Mary Phagan was a 13 year old child
laborer just consider that from home and
she was a 13 year old child laborer
who did a repetitive task she inserted
rubber erasers into eraser tips at the
National pencil company on Forsyth
Street in downtown Atlanta day after day
hour after hour she earned pennies an
hour she had no hope of going to high
school
forget about college and the terrible
thing was that Atlanta capitalist and
industrialist thought this was good
they thought it was hygienic to have
children working in factories well the
mothers and fathers of these children
knew it was not good they knew that it
was absolutely wrong and they were
ashamed and upset that they were so
impoverished they had to send their
children off to earn pennies an hour in
factories so Mary her life was cut off
at age thirteen we know very very little
about her I was very proud in my book
that I was even able to quote from a
postcard she wrote her cousin Myrtle bar
more but that's about the only time
we've heard Mary's voice so she was a
child laborer as to why we remember this
murder I think even today this murder
would get our attention I mean you're
right sad to say we live in an age now
in which atrocity after atrocity is just
another piece of news but the Fagin
murder was particularly brutal she was
found in the pencil factory by a night
watchman making his rounds she was so
badly beat up that the watchman couldn't
determine her race the pencil factory
was filled with pencil grinds and coal
dust and she'd been dragged and battered
in all that and so it was a terribly
horrific crime and then there were these
strange notes placed by the body and I'm
just going to read one of them and if
I've got any budding linguistics
students out there I urge you to write a
master's thesis about this or a doctoral
thesis but one of the notes read ma'am
that Negro hired down here did this I
went to make water and he pushed me down
that hole a long tall negro black that
who it was long slim tall negro I write
while play with me at
absolutely wild and it was on the front
page of the Atlanta Journal the next day
so a child laborer found dead in the
basement of a child labor factory that
was an earthquake going on that you know
set in motion these underlying class and
religious fault lines because Leo Frank
was Jewish and it didn't help that
Atlanta was in the midst of a horrific
newspaper war there were three
independent newspapers in Atlanta at the
time the journal the Constitution and
the Atlanta Georgian which was owned by
women Randolph Hearst and we all think
that we are unique in living in an age
of media bombardment but if you were
living in a big city in America in 1913
you would know what it was like
multiple extras every day and the Hearst
paper just went filed with this story so
I think we would notice it if it
happened today who was Leo Frank Leo
Frank was the exact opposite of Mary
Phagan Leo Frank was a quiet rational
extremely well educated mechanical
engineer graduated from Cornell
University he went to Germany to study
pencil making at Everhard favored the
gigantic pencil manufacturer he learned
state-of-the-art techniques he was a
scientist he was interested in modern
management techniques and when the
National pencil company was capitalized
they hired him to come down here and run
this big factory and it was a huge
factory it turned out hundreds of
thousands of pencils a week the factory
was the company was later renamed
scripto but he was a quiet rational
chess playing Strauss loving of cerebral
introvert dogs and a stranger in the
south but he married into one of the
best families one of the best Jewish
families in Atlanta the ceilings and to
give you an idea the ceilings slicked
ceiling who went to the University of
Georgia helped John Portman put together
all the property in downtown Atlanta on
which Peachtree Center stands so this is
a very advantageous marriage that Leo
Frank made
now very quickly another person became
centerpiece in this case and that was
Jim Connelly who was Jim Connelly and
why did he become such a powerful figure
in this case Jim Connelly was the
janitor at the National pencil company
and he was often drunk he was often
arrested and he passed himself off as
illiterate and a fool and a prankster
several weeks after the murder of Mary
Phagan as Atlanta had wondered how this
crime happened and read all these
accounts in the newspaper and Leo Frank
had been arrested he was the last person
to admit having seen Mary Phagan alive
Leo Frank would be arrested even today
and the early investigation focused on
timetables and who arrived at the
factory first and the results of Mary
Fagin's autopsy and what time did she
die and what time did the murder occur
but it was like trench warfare in World
War one neither side was really
advancing and Jim Connelly came along
and through a circuitous number of
events the police determined that he
wrote the murder notes that were found
in the basement
beside Marie Jenkins body and the rub
was he told the police that Leo Frank
dictated those notes to him to pin the
crime on yet another black man
the Leo Frank was in the habit of
seducing young women at the pencil
factory and that Connelly had served as
Leo Frank's guard during his acid
Nations and that one of the acid Nations
the one with Mary Phagan got out of hand
and Leo Frank was violent and Mary
Phagan
ended up dead and that's who Jim column
of us and I think that Connelly had
first told the police he could write yes
that was the key thing Jim Connelly told
the police he couldn't write and the
police discovered a number of io u--'s
that Jim Connelly had signed for jewelry
he was buying on time at downtown
jewelry stores and Jim Connelly had two
years of education with two terrific
teachers both graduates
Atlanta University complex one of whom
would go on to be the legendary
librarian of the Auburn Avenue library
through the 1930s and 40s and you know
explain books to some of Atlanta's
budding young black leaders but the
police found out he could write and his
response he was so ingenuously one had
to love him he said bike hooks on a liar
and that was fine now what happened at
the trial that made him such a central
figure in this whole thing what did he
say Conley took the stand about two
weeks into the trial and the trial was
at a stalemate
and the day that he was going to take
the stand the trial was held in a
temporary building at the corner of
Hunter and Pryor Street downtown across
from where the current Fulton County
Courthouse is and there was a line out
the door for blocks
to get in and Connally testified and
Connally got on the stand and I'm just
going to read you a few sentences that
Conley had to say and I want you to
imagine the scene a black man in a
packed courtroom with people surrounding
the court building all the eyes of
Atlanta upon him a solitary black man in
a sea of white faces and the prosecutor
asked him what happened to Mary Phagan
and Conley said mr. Frank was standing
at the head of the stairs shivering he
was rubbing his hands together and
acting funny he had a little cord in his
hands his eyes was large
they looked funny and wild he asked me
if I saw a little girl pass along there
and I told him yes he says she came up
to my office a while ago and I wanted to
know something about her work and I went
back there to see if the little girls
were could come and I wanted to be with
the little girl and she refused me and I
struck her and I guess I struck her too
hard and she hit her hit her head
against something of course you know I
built like other men the reason he said
that was I had seen him in a position
I haven't seen any other man that has
got children I have seen him in the
office two or three times before and a
lady was in his office and she was
sitting down in a chair and she had her
clothes up to here and he was down on
his knees now just imagine that a black
man saying that in a white filled
courtroom in 1913 it's astonishing
circumcision oral sex subjects that
would never be talked about in polite
company are suddenly introduced into the
public conversation the judge and you
women in the audience have to love this
his first reaction was to send all women
from the courtroom so the rest of the
trial took place in front of an
exclusively male audience Connolly was
on the stand three days the defense
submitted to him him to one of those
brutal cross examinations you could ever
read about and he was stood that
cross-examination largely intact and in
Atlanta Georgia reporter road after
Conley step down from the stand if the
story Conley tells is a lie then it is
the most amazingly sustained lie ever
told in Georgia and then the Atlanta
Georgia and one of the headline writers
and this speaks the language of a
different time the front page headline
on the Atlanta Georgian was the Ebony
chevalier of crime dark town's own hero
that was Jim Connolly now much has been
made about the prosecution in the case
that this was that they were
anti-semitic what's your reaction to
that the prosecution was anti-semitic
mildly Hugh Dorsey the Solicitor General
pointed up
Frank's wealth but it wasn't overtly
anti-semitic the defense was racist
the defense hammered it Jim Connolly
they said things about Jim
like that you wouldn't ever repeat I
closed them in my book but it's it's a
textbook case in white racism and but
you know when when the trial ended in
the closing arguments Ruben Arnold who
along with Luther also was Frank's
counselor he made in his closing
argument a statement that the Frank was
it that the trial was anti-semitic and
when it was over and Frank was
pronounced guilty Hugh Dorsey was lifted
bodily out of the courtroom and carried
like a football hero out to a waiting
car his feet never touched the ground
and people were standing in skyscrapers
all around the courthouse with the
windows big sash windows up and they
were waving handkerchiefs and they were
who's eyeing and cheering for you Dorsey
and you know that was a sense that the
entire city of Atlanta had turned
against Leo Frank now was that over
anti-semitism it was I'll say one more
thing about the end of the trial when
the verdict was delivered the prosecutor
and the defense lawyers met with the
judge and they agreed to the judges
suggestion that Frank not be present in
the courtroom when the verdict was
returned because they felt if Frank was
acquitted he would be lynched so the
atmosphere let's just say it was
poisonous and the charge has always been
made that the crowd outside the
courtroom yelled hang the Jew or
something like that did that actually
happen did you find evidence of that no
that didn't happen
you know later it would be reported but
later the Frank case would become you
know a back and forth propaganda war and
that line wouldn't emerge until a couple
years later on okay which brings us to
the second part of this and that is of
course the case becoming far beyond
Georgia becoming a national cause celeb
how did that happen how did this case go
from being something that every
everybody in Atlanta and Georgia was
playing attention to to becoming a
national cause there were only two or
three national newspaper articles about
Leo Frank
during the trial but within a few days
after Frank's conviction David marks the
rabbi at the reformed synagogue the
temple got on the train and went to New
York and he sought out the leaders of
American Jewish community sought out a
dog the publisher of the New York Times
he sought out Lewis Marshall a great
constitutional lawyer who is known as
the attorney at large of the Jewish
people and he sought out an advertising
genius named Albert Lasker who sort of
invented modern advertising and
initially these men were sort of
resistant to rabbi Marx's plea that
Frank was a victim of anti-semitism but
rabbi Marx
finally sold them that this was an
anti-semitic case and you know they
marshaled all the resources of modern
media to exonerate Leo Frank laughter
was an advertising genius say he
represented Lucky Strike cigarettes and
Budweiser beer and but it was really a
doll Fox from the New York Times that
made this case a national case in
December of 1914 right as the drumbeat
is really beginning December one month
the New York Times published 33 articles
about the front case and five editorials
it was excessive and in fairness to Leo
for in fairness Adolph Ochs Adolph Ochs
thought he understood what had happened
here Adolph Ochs was born in the north
but he grew up in Tennessee and got his
start as a newspaper man in Chattanooga
his family still owns the Chattanooga
Times and they were Southern
sympathizers and in this year of debate
about the Confederate flag gone oxes
mother was she spent most of her
girlhood between Natchez and Nashville
and when she died she was buried with
Confederate flags so Adolph Ochs
thought he understood the south and he
thought that if the south got the facts
as he saw them about the Leo Frank case
Leo Frank would be exonerated and Tom
Watson became obviously a lightning rod
in this case at this point he comes into
this story now when this has become a
national case tell us about him and and
how he plays into the story Tom Watson
is really one of the most brilliant
frustrating upsetting
people in all of southern history I
simultaneously admire him and am
terrified by but he called himself the
agrarian rebel he was from Thompson he
also called himself the sage of McDuffie
and McDuffie County if you know your 159
counties and he took it upon himself to
rebut the New York Times
week after week in the pages of the
Jeffersonian and Tom Watson was not
someone you wanted as an enemy Tom
Watson was a brilliant writer he was
great trial lawyer he was a student of
Napoleon and he identified with the
common man and he believed that the
forces of capital were going to grind
down the memory of this poor working
girl Mary Phagan and they were going to
use privilege and influence and the
power of the jewish-owned press to
exonerate Leo Frank into getting out and
when Watson started his crusade the
Jeffersonian was a handsome newspaper it
was quite well produced it had a
circulation of 25,000 when it started
its crusade by the end the circulation
was 87,000 which may not sound like a
lot but that was a lot almost all of it
was in Georgia and C Vann Woodward the
great Pulitzer prize-winning historian
in his biography of Tom Watson
absolutely fabulous book he says that
when trains came into rural Georgia
towns carrying copies of their Jeff got
to wait for you Jeff that stacks of the
Jeff would melt like snowflakes you know
before they even got to the newsstand
now people would buy them hop off the
train would you characterize him as any
semitic I would say that Tom Watson used
anti-semitic rhetoric viciously against
Leo Frank whether Tom Watson was
anti-semitic in his soul I'm not so sure
Tom Watson was unfair he was deceitful
he was vengeful
but he was not a bred in the bone
anti-semite as I understand
anti-semitism if the New York Times had
not taken up this cause if they had not
beat the drum so loudly that Frank was
innocent I guess to two ways to ask his
question would he have died a peaceful
death in prison do we lay this at their
doorstep or would he have been would he
have been executed would governor
Slayton have ever taken up the cause
without the New York Times
what role did they play in his death I
think of the New York Times case as you
might think of a radical regimen of
chemotherapy it's going to extend your
life for a while but then it's going to
kill you and the New York Times
championed Leo Frank very effectively
and they championed him as the case was
going through its appellate machinations
ultimately up to the United States
Supreme Court and you know we live in a
world of influence it was a world of
influence even then and for the New York
Times to be championing Leo Frank
they're being held in Washington DC that
was a powerful thing and I think that
extended Frank's life but it contributed
to the backlash in Georgia that
ultimately curtailed Frank's life so it
is a double-edged sword so how does this
case wind up on governor john Slayton's
desk the United States Supreme Court
turns down Frank's last appeal in april
of 1915 and the case comes back to
georgia it first lands at the prison
commission which was a three member body
that functioned back in those days as a
pardon and parole board and the
microphone to it and the part of our old
ward the prison Commission decided that
Frank's a dog so the case then came to
governor Slayton and governor Slayton
was the outgoing governor he didn't want
this he wanted no part of it he had a
conflict of interest his law partner was
Luther Oh sir Frank's lead counsel
but Slayton and what I think was I mean
decisions of conscience are not played
out between bright lines we live in gray
areas and Slayton in this gray area of
conflict about his law partner on the
one hand and what he decided was a
decision of conscience on the other
decided to take the case and he held
hearings at the State Capitol
and you know the hearings were not
conducted under the rule of law so
people would talk about anything and the
transcripts of them are absolutely
fascinating and I quote from them
liberally in my book but as Slayton was
holding these hearings out on the
Washington Street steps of the Capitol
was fiddlin John Carson the great
hillbilly musician and it's hard to
conjure who fiddlin John Carson was for
today's audience he was kind of like a
precursor of Hank Williams
I mean if he'd had his druthers he'd
rather gone honky-tonkin but he also
could touch that mournful note in
hillbilly music and the note best
expressed by a solitary fiddle and so he
stood on the steps and played his fiddle
and sang the ballot of Mary Phagan
which is really an Appalachian chant and
so just imagine the state capitol
downtown Atlanta and this lonely fiddler
standing there a crowd around him
chanting little Mary Phagan she went to
work one day she went to the pencil
factory to get her little pay Leo Frank
he met her with a brute Lee heart we
know he smiled and said little Mary now
you go home no more he killed little
Mary Phagan was on one holiday and
called for old Jim Connelly to take her
body away judge Rhone passed the
sentence you bet he passed it well
solicitor Huey M Dorothy sent Leo Frank
to
and he didn't say the last word he just
let it hang there and that was the voice
of Georgia that was the voice of the
common man in Georgia expressed in song
and it was a powerful voice and you know
fiddlin John Carson his grandson was a
great athlete at the University of
Georgia Johnny Carson he was a
all-american football player at things
as an all-american golf player maybe the
only two-time all-american at Georgia
and I mention that because fiddlin John
Carson and the Carson family this was
you know the heart of Georgia speaking
so governor Slayton commutes the
sentence from from from death to life in
prison in the last days of his office
and he's in office pandemonium ensues
Georgia reacts as you would expect
there's a wild protest set off the
governor has to declare martial law
how does Tom wants to react and what
role does he play and what happened next
well in the first post commutation issue
of the Jeffersonian Watson called
for Frank's lynching and he did it in
the most extraordinary rhetoric and you
know when I say I'm both amazed and
appalled by Tom Watson he began by
summoning the Confederate war dead out
of their graves and urging men to honor
the memory of the dead veterans and just
so powerful and so wrong and this is a
time you know forget about Confederate
iconography the veterans were still
alive and this touched just such a
strong note and then Tom Watson was a
lawyer and because Luther Rosser was
John Clayton's
law partner Watson argued like a logger
in his first statement and let me just
read you these two lines hereafter let
no man reproach the south with Flint's
law let him remember the unendurable
provocation
let him say whether Lynch law is not
better than no law at all but Rosser and
Slaton have together done nullifies the
code abolish --is the course and sponges
us into administrative anarchy that's a
legal statement he's saying the lynching
is legal all bets are off so you know
the horsemen of the apocalypse got
saddled up if you will Steve take a
moment and walk us through what we see
behind us right here starting in the top
left sitting at the driver's seat there
in that car is a young man named Herbert
Eugene clay and he was the Solicitor
General of the old Blue Ridge Circuit
Court which ran from Marietta up to the
Tennessee state line and those are some
of the bells of Marietta those are two
of his brothers on one running board
that's a man named Devereaux McClatchy
on the other running board and if you
look at that wily grin of Herbert clay
you recognize a young man to whom no one
has ever said the word note and
Herbert's father was the United States
Senator Herbert's brother Lucius clay
was the military governor of Germany at
the end of World War two and Herbert
clay was one of the planners of the Leo
Frank lynching the other picture is of
the lynching and I mean it's a hideous
image it's fascinating to me because
there's a race like young man standing
just to the left of the tree and that
nine year old Norville Lassiter and I
got to know Norville pretty well and
Norville had some very vivid memories of
what he saw there so this is the cause
and that's the effect so this is Tuesday
August 17th 1915 Leo Frank is lynched
who did it well the lynching worked on a
number of levels there were five or six
eminent men here in Marietta who planned
it one was
Herbie gene clay another was Newton
Augustus Morris he was the just retired
judge of the blue ridge circuit court
another one was John Tucker Dorsey who
was a lawyer from Marietta and was a
representative and the state legislature
were very important to our story he was
the chairman of the prison subcommittee
of the Georgia Legislature Bolen Glover
Brumby who ran a chair manufacturing
company here in town and quite a
prominent family
former governor Joseph Brown and Fred
Morris a lawyer brave man interesting
man who had played football for the
University of Georgia when Pop Warner
was the coach and these men set out to
execute Leo Frank and they appointed
several lieutenants to run the lynch
Party and the chief lieutenants were
black Newt Morris who was in charge of
the Cobb County chain gang and he was
judged newts double first cousin and he
was named black Newt because he had a
dark complexion and he was a pretty
tough character he carried a bullwhip
coiled on his shoulder and someone I who
knew him told me he could get with him
down on the chain gang and George
Danielle was the other leader he had a
jewelry store here on the square and
they picked the 25 to 30 men who would
serve as the muscle and then they ran
the show wants the Lynch party left
Marietta to go get Leo Frank described
what happened if you can on the car ride
back from Milledgeville what was that
like well they got in and out of the
prison in an astonishingly short time
and you know this is a state prison with
guard towers well armed guard force the
Lynch party walked right in
they took Leo Frank without firing a
shot the only hitch is they left one of
the party members and they had to double
back and get him
and then they started driving and just
imagine seven cars in the dead of night
in Georgia in 1915 not only are there no
waffle houses but they are just speeding
through the night and they take a very
circuitous route there was a electrician
named yellowjacket Brown who'd gone down
ahead of the party on his motorcycle and
he cut all the telephone lines and
drained the gas tanks or disconnected
the distributor caps on the engines of
the cars that the guard used at the
present and but he neglected to get one
phone line and so a party of lawmen was
out in Fulton County in Atlanta and the
Lynch party skirted far to the east they
came up across the little river near
where the nuclear power plant is now the
Harley branch power plant and they came
up through Eatonton and on through
social circle and winder they may have
gotten as far north as winder and when
they got to Marietta
they were coming from the north it
looked like they'd been up in the North
Georgia Mountains that came down through
Alpharetta which was in the seat of
now-defunct Milton County they picked up
a couple of the leaders of the party and
they came on in and lunch lil Frank did
they give you that back thank you your
mic starts working when I do that but
describe the scene that we see behind us
at the lynching what was it like it was
horrible it was hideous you know
initially it was quiet hanging just
thought to be a humane form because when
it's effectively administered the
hanging victim died immediately from a
broken neck the Atlanta Constitution had
a line in its first day news story about
the lynching that I can't get out of my
mind
Leo Frank undoubtedly played the air
that can't stop thinking about that even
12 years after writing this
and so for 20 or 30 minutes it was quiet
and then a crowd started to build and
then an enormous crowd started to build
and people were running them they were
coming on bicycles and buy cars and you
know soon enough there were between
three and five thousand people gathered
around this tree with Leo Frank's body
hanging there and there was one fella in
particular in the crowd named robert e
lee howell and robert e lee how was a
wild man and robert e lee how wanted to
burn and desecrate Frank's body and
judge Newt Morris one of the planners
took it upon himself to rescue Frank's
body from the mob so Frank's body was
cut down and it was again a hideous
scene robert e lee how somehow rested
Frank's body away from the Undertaker's
and how stomped on Frank's face with his
boots and Judge Morris got the body back
into a wicker basket which were then
commonplace for transporting the dead
and threw it in the back of the wagon
with a couple black hands and started up
Roswell Street toward the federal
cemetery and they got about halfway up
Rockwell as well and a lawyer named John
wood pulled up in his car and judge
Morris beckoned him over and they threw
Frank's body into the back of the car
and they drove on down to the
Chattahoochee River and across the river
and into Atlanta and luckily for history
there was an otherwise unheralded
Atlanta Journal reporter named Rogers
winter who judge Morris said get on with
me and winter hung on to the running
board of his car as John wood drove into
Atlanta and he would stop and take notes
and he stumbled into the office of the
Atlanta Journal excuse me covered with
dust and sat down and wrote one of the
greatest dead line accounts ever written
by the newspaper reporter it's often
anthologized and books of best newspaper
writing but that's how Frank's body got
back to Atlanta they put him in a
at a funeral home crowd of Atlantians
learned he was behind the garage they
were going to break down the garage the
funeral home director moved Frank's body
in a cheap pine box into a temporary
viewing area on a couple saw horses in
the front of the funeral home and 15,000
people it's hard to believe 15 thousand
people filed by before the Frank family
could finally get Frank's body onto a
train that night then get it up to New
York all of this revealed in your book
Billy for the first time most of what we
know about the lynching you discovered
how did you do it how did you find all
this out I'm painstaking and I'm
stubborn and I just stuck with it and
that's basically all there's no magic I
stuck with it who's your best source
well I very luckily had Bill Kenny who
was the associate editor of the Marietta
Journal take a liking to me bill is now
91 years young he's not quite feeling
well enough to be here tonight but bill
didn't ever really tell me anything but
he would say here's like you ought to
ask people here's who you ought to go
see why don't you go see so-and-so and
then come back and tell me what they
told you so he sent me off to see George
Morris early in my research George
Morris was the oldest son of Judge
numerous George Morris had been a bank
examiner in California come back to
Marietta to retire and I had a long
interview with George Morris I was very
proud of myself because George Morris
had been at the scene of the lynching he
was 19 years old he rode his bicycle out
there when Frank's body was fresh on the
tree and he told me everything he saw
and it was incredibly vivid and as I say
I was very proud of myself for getting
his description and I went back to see
Bill Kenny and I patted myself on the
back as I was telling him the story and
he said you missed it I said what do you
mean it was a great story and he said
why was George Morris out there and I
said I don't know he said because his
dad told him to go out there and I said
well what does that mean
he said you still don't get it his dad
knew Leo Frank's body was hanging out
there before anybody else in Marietta
knew that tells you his dad's role in
this George Morris just gave you a very
important piece of information so that's
how my relationship with Bill went and
Bill bill was very tolerant of me he
just let me keep coming back and didn't
kick me out other good sources well the
hardest journalistic cold call I've ever
made in my life is I flew down to
Sarasota Florida pretty early in my
research to meet with Eugene Herbert
clay jr. the son of Herbert clay there
at the wheel of the car and Eugene clay
was in his mid-70s he was a practicing
lawyer sweet man and talented man and I
walked into his old fashioned law office
in Sarasota and near a banyan tree and
he knew I was coming he let me end and
essentially I said did your father Lynch
Leo Frank and he started crying and so
I'm standing there with a 75 year old
man crying and it's my fault and but we
got through that and we talked about it
and his mom and dad had gotten divorced
when he was five or six years old and
she got in custody and raised him up
north and Rhode Island so he didn't
really know much about his dad and so
our purposes dovetailed I wanted to find
out about his dad's role in the lynching
he wanted to find out who his dad was so
we corresponded frequently about this
and then one long weekend we met here in
Marietta and we went around talking to
just about every person we could find 85
years or older who knew his dad and we
spent an amazing day with a bond
salesman named Lex jolly who Herbert
clay senior after the lynching went on
to be President of the Georgia Senate
and Lex was his page we talked to a
retired Superior Court
judge Luther Hanes judge Hanes had been
a law partner in Herbert seniors law
firm and so Herbert Eugene clay jr. and
I would sit listening to these people
tell us about Herbert clay and I started
to piece together the role and one other
little side note about the Clay's one of
the strangely effective things I did
researching this is I read the society
news obsessively about Marietta for two
or three years before the lynching in
two or three years after and all three
Atlanta papers ran a society and notes
column in each Sunday's paper filed by a
local correspondent and they're
absolutely fascinating documents and
they'd be full of recipes and party
lists and I was interested because I
started to see how the men who planned
the lynching how they related to each
other and how they socialize with each
other but one of these stories showed
that on the weekend of the lynching
Herbert clays wife and young Eugene
Herbert jr. had gone with Luke
Evelyn clay who was Herbert senior's
sister on vacation to st. Augustine and
I showed Herbert jr. this yellowing clip
and he remembered going down there at
five or six years of age and he said the
week the week of the lynching the day of
the lynching they were on vacation down
in st. Augustine he said this means so
much to me my mother hated my aunt I
never knew even as a little boy I knew
it was wrong that we'd all be on
vacation together in st. Augustine so it
was you know gathering threads just
trying to you know weave a a garment out
of these little bits and pieces that I
was collecting and who - who told you
who gave you the names of the people who
actually went on the raiding party -
Milledgeville well the great good
fortune to make friends with a couple of
aging women Dorothy
Haney Smith and Gomer gol ma are Bulmer
Annie Wilson and their dad Lawrence
was in the lunch party and Dorothy went
to secretarial school and when she got
out in the early 1950s she saturd that
down and her dad gave her a list of
everyone in the lunch party and she and
I went over that list again and again
and she had an interesting take on this
so she worked as a beautician for many
years at different shops on and off the
square of Marietta and she worked on the
hair of the wives and daughters of a lot
of the people who were involved in the
lynching and she gleaned little facts
about the story that she would share
with me and she always felt that her dad
who was part of the muscle on the Lynch
party had been used so by the rich men
so she was proud and happy to try to
give me that angle and then Gomer who
was a little bit older Gomer was I think
six years old the summer the luncheon
she wasn't as helpful on that in that
she had concrete memories of the day of
the lynching and to me the most
important one is she was up at 7:30 or
8:00 that morning when her dad came in
from having killed Leo Frank and she was
a as we all are over six or seven
impress whoa and we look up at heart our
fathers and he was standing in their
house sobbing and she said I'd never
seen my dad cry before and that he
walked off into a field behind the house
and started pulling corn and you know it
was a I got so much from these two women
both a visceral understanding of the
emotional lives of the lunch party
members and you know that the names
themselves what was the most astonishing
thing to you about all this about this
lynching but to me it's a
state-sponsored crime it was run through
the Georgia Legislature there was a
typhus outbreak at the Millersville
prison in the summer of 1915 and an
investigation was threatened and so the
legislature sent a group down there
chaired by John Tucker Dorsey who was
part of the Lynch Party brain thrust to
get to the bottom
of the typhus outbreak so suddenly they
had the warden and his team as we now
say on tender hooks and the warden in
his group could stand aside and let the
lynch party in or they could face you
know possible charges and they stood
aside and then within weeks of the
lynching the legislature appropriated
thirty thousand dollars in funding for
new construction and state prison now
was that a quid pro quo
I make a very strong case for it in my
book I don't think we'll ever know for
sure but to me that's the most
astonishing thing about it that you know
this was a Marietta conceived but
state-run event well the Lynch party
leaders ran the legal system in Cobb
County
Herbert clay was chairman of the grand
jury that investigated the case and they
returned a no bill they did not indict
they said they could find no one in Cobb
County who had any responsibility
several of their witnesses were in fact
in the lunch party on the coroner's
inquests was equally bogus
it's the Woody Allen line a mockery of a
fraud of a sham and there were no civil
rights statutes there was no federal law
there was no mechanism for this to
become a federal case there was barely
even an FBI so once an investigation
cleared a local grand jury in 1915 it
was over the the only attempt anyone
made to get at this legally is there was
brief discussion of prosecuting Tom
Watson for sending obscenity through the
mails and you know Watson got with most
members of the Georgia delegation and
that went away so there are a few
unsolved mysteries left in this case
what are some of them what happened to
the man that a lot of attention has
focused on since the Jim Connelly
ultimately what happened in Jim Tom Lee
was convicted as an accessory after the
fact and he served a year in a chain
gang and
Boulton County and then Jim Conley set
off on a tear he must have been arrested
ten times in a three year period
mostly for crimes against women one of
them the newspaper used a phrase that
shows you you know how usage has changed
he was accused of bride beating and he
would be given a misdemeanor a slap on
the wrist and Atlanta largely looked at
this as proof of Jim Connolly's ferocity
that Jim Connolly was too simple-minded
and drunken and violent a soul to have
imagined and presented a case against
leo Frank
and finally Jim Connolly was arrested
for a more serious crime armed robbery
at a store in South Atlanta he served a
number of years in Reidsville he got out
he was arrested again in the 1940s for
playing what was then called the bug
betting on a number that would appear in
the Atlanta papers each day and you
would you know people would run around
taking book on this in downtown Atlanta
and then he essentially disappeared and
there's no death certificate for him in
my obsessive way he lived in Vine City
over the Georgia Dome is and there was
very little of it left but I am both
luckily and sadly old enough to remember
Vine City and many of the roads were
unpaved even when I was working on this
and I walked up and down the streets
trying to find people who knew Jim
Connolly and you know there was method
in my madness I let some of the black
creatures in the neighborhood do my work
for me and I got them to gather the
older members of their congregation into
fellowship halls and I would meet and
talk with them about Jim Connolly and I
just kept striking out and so he
essentially just disappeared I called
off the dogs when someone told me that
oh you ought to start going to church
graveyards to see if it was a private
very you know death certificate but if
you know you walk from one graveyard to
another you might find a stone and and I
didn't do that
is there still information out there do
you think I think there is I mean
there's all kinds of information the
handcuffs that were on leo Frank's body
are said to be someplace here in
Marietta the nature Leo Frank was
wearing when he was lynched for years
part of it was displayed behind a frame
at a Roadhouse just down 41 from
Marietta the Haney sisters told me that
their dad Lawrence not only gave them a
list of names he gave them a narrative
of the kidnapping and lynching of Leo
Frank he sat down and told them the
story and they wrote it all out and they
had it and they gave it to another
family and it passed on to yet another
family in Alabama I'm pretty confident
that narrative exists but I haven't seen
it and so any of y'all in the audience
habit give it to Stan he'll know what to
do with it let's move on to the what
happened after 1915 the aftermath this
case talk to us about Lucille Frank what
happened to her and the impact in the
Atlanta Jewish community on this case
the same day I went to Florida meet her
bikini clad junior for the same week I
went to st. Petersburg to meet Alan
Marcus Allen Marcus was Lucille's nephew
and we had lunch and we were talking and
he said well you know what happened to
aunt Lucille I said no and he said well
we buried her I said yes people do and
he said no we buried her and then he I
said what do you mean he said well she
died in 1958 I think that's the right
year she wanted her ashes she want her
body cremated and she wanted her ashes
scattered in a park in Atlanta and there
was a city ordinance prohibiting the
distribution of remains so the assets
stayed in a cardboard box at Patterson's
funeral home on Spring Street and they
say there for five or six years and then
the funeral home was doing inventory and
they called Alan Marcus and said you've
got to come and get
blue steel Frank's ashes so they came
and got him and they put them in the
trunk of Allan's Corvair and both of
Alan's sons are here this evening Chuck
and Gary Marcus and you know they drove
Lucille's asses around his teenagers in
the car that was you know the joke that
was driving this Lucille and you know
then one morning I mean this is in the
memory of most of us in the room one
morning in the mid-60s Alan and his
brother got some gardening tools and
really before light went down to the
Jewish section of Oakland Cemetery and
buried Lucille and Anna nomina anonymous
plot between the headstones of her
parents and so Alan tells me this whole
mind-blowing heart-wrenching story over
lunch and you know I'm moved and I
immediately at that point I knew I would
finish the book just to tell that story
of that alone and to me that represents
what happened to Atlanta's Jewish
community because of the Leo Frank
lynching it was a body blow to the
psyche of Atlanta's Jews such a body
blow that you know even nearly 50 years
later the family of Lucille Frank this
martyr was afraid to conduct a public
funeral service for Lucille and you know
a couple of other things that happened
the temple bombing had occurred in the
interim so Atlanta's Jews were on pins
and needles about that their number of
anti-semitic web sites out there today
that claim that Lucille Frank was buried
in Oakland Cemetery because she didn't
want to be buried next to her husband in
New York because she knew he was guilty
and that's a horrible and untrue an
awful thing to say but it's evidence of
how polarized this case is because
there's still a number of people who you
know firmly believe that Leo Frank was
championed by the forces of capital
elite Jewish media that
didn't want to see a Jewish defendant
pay for the life of a Gentile girl
two-part question how should how did
this case affect Marietta and we don't
believe in blood corruption in this
country so how are people in Marietta
today supposed to feel about this in
your opinion I came to a funny
resolution or realization better word
Marietta was affected by this exactly as
Atlanta's Jewish community was affected
and you may wonder what does he mean but
I got to know one of Judge Morris's
daughters Lucille sugar Morris and we
had a couple of great conversations and
she was 16 or 17 years old the summer of
the lynching and she grew up to be a
young woman in the 30s and 40s and she
would shop at a now-defunct women's
store on Peachtree Street JP Allen it
was the best women's clothing store in
Atlanta for a number of years and
Lucille worked at JP Allen at the glove
counter so sugar would come in to JP
Allen to buy things and Lucille Frank
would wait on sugar and sugar told me
well Lucille Frank she was so lovely she
was just a wonderful woman and it's so
sad what happened to her husband and
when she told me that I realized sugar
didn't know but her dad had done Lucille
Frank didn't know what Sugar's dad had
done and that gave me a real insight
into why no one in either Marietta or
Atlanta's Jewish community wanted to
talk about this it was just too close
people were too tied up together up
another quick example of that well we'll
leave it at that that's a good two
questions the end this there were 22
lynchings of african-americans in
Georgia in 1915 why are we talking about
this case we're talking about the
franklin qing for a couple of reasons
one Frank was abducted from a state
prison not a County Jail
- it was a crime of premeditation most
lynchings of blacks and Georgia were
spontaneous outbursts you can't draw an
equivalency between a good lynching and
a bad lynching they were all bad
lynchings but three the magnitude of
difficulty of the Frank lynching the
conclusion from those two facts I just
gave you was off the charts and then
finally the Frank lynching inspired the
resurrection of the modern Ku Klux Klan
and it gave purpose to the then just
formed anti-defamation league so the
Frank lynching lives with us in the
polarized debate and hostility that we
hear in American discourse 100 years
later most contemporary writers now
believe as I think you do that Leo Frank
was innocent is there any chance that he
was guilty there is a chance Leo Frank
was guilty the prosecution presented a
credible case against him to dismiss Jim
comley's testimony out of hand is to not
listen to what Jim Connelly had to say
Jim Connolly was a fabulous witness and
I read every single word of his
testimony and there were days that he
had me convinced moreover at both the
coroner's inquest and at the trial a
number of young women accused Leo Frank
of what today would be called sexual
harassment were they all lying that
doesn't mean that Frank was a murderer
but was there a pattern of behavior in
the pencil factory that would have led a
young woman like Murray Fagan to be at
peril but ultimately I concluded that
Conley did it primarily because of a
study that a lawyer named William Smith
who'd been Conley's lawyer did of these
murder notes he compared the murder
notes one of which is behind us compared
the language Conley had a penchant to
use compound adjectives long tall black
in everything he wrote and said at the
trial Hugh Dorsey the prosecutor in his
closing argument said old Jim every time
he was on the stand he said I'd done it
that's the difference between ignorance
and education Jim
done he didn't know the word did William
Smith took apart all of Jim Connolly's
writings Jim Connolly Oh Lisa's the word
did correctly Jim Connelly wrote those
notes Jim Connelly Frank didn't have
anything to do with the murder notes and
to me the authorship of those notes you
know places this crime at Jim Connolly's
hands if you will describe these two
slides behind us what are we looking at
well first on the left we're looking at
a photograph of Mary Phagan grave in the
city cemetery just across the way and
it's a fascinating photograph for a
number of reasons one you see the face
of the man has been blacked out that's
most likely one of the lynchers and
maybe if somebody in the audience
recognizes those telltale ears you might
do a little soul searching to the
picture he holds in his hand that's more
evidence that he was in the lynch Party
it's I've never seen this picture except
in this picture of a picture there's
nobody around the lynching tree this
picture was taken immediately after
Frank was lynched this was before the
crowd had gathered three the oak leaves
those are limbs that were taken from the
tree branches that Frank was hung from
so this is a statement this this is a
come full circle this is vengeance this
is testimony to the successful vengeance
that Cobb County sought behind me
immediately is Leo Frank's grave in
Queens and Stern was the married name of
Frank's sister so it's a stern Frank
fought and on the foot stone for Leo
Frank it says semper eadem which is
Latin for as it's always been it's a
very dark statement about anti-semitism
it's ever been thus as we in tonight I
want to say is we stand on the brink of
the centennial of this case it's fair to
ask and the Georgia Historical Society
got asked a lot about this case and
about this program and others why are we
having this program why are we doing
this why is it important for us as a
society to revisit these painful parts
of our collective past what purpose does
it serve what purpose does it serve the
Georgia Historical Society is a public
history educational and research
institutions believes that when we
studied the past yes we can learn much
from our triumphs that we can all
celebrate but we can also learn equally
from our tragedies the nature of our
humanity we think is never more revealed
than in the moments of great personal
and community crisis where hatred
brutality and violence are often mingled
with courage compassion and character it
is if you think about it at the heart of
the American story whether in Marietta
in 1915 walking up the steps of Little
Rock High School in 1957 or in a
Charleston Church in 2015 this case
still deeply touches us all after 100
years we did not come here to judge but
to understand better the human condition
we cannot claim to stand on any higher
moral ground and the historical actors
in tonight's story because make no
mistake we are still collectively
bedeviled by the prejudices and problems
that led to the murders of these two
people you see behind me we are
compelled to remember their story and
revisit it from time to time to see if
we can make sense of what happened to
them because as you've said at the
beginning it is still our story and we
risk our own future if we don't return
to walk over this ground thank you all
very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you all very much we have a
microphone set up to our left and we
welcome members of the audience to come
up in ask questions
that's a long walk down with the
microphone like the old Billy Graham
Crusades come on down
Jim Connelly testifying against Leo
free-thinking to the microphone sorry
Jim Connelly come in talking of
testifying against Leo Frank would that
have been legal at the time oh yes you
could take evidence from black people I
was as I thought the blacks couldn't
testify against whites at the time after
emancipation in nineteen Engl for 1863
that he was a blacks could serve on
juries at the time okay I'm mistaken now
in the antebellum period that's true
other questions
hi - Peter yeah Park Marietta resident a
quick question for you it seems to me
startling
we haven't heard much from the people
who are participated in the lynching
right did they never speak about it it
seems like most people who are involved
in conspiracy eventually someone does
speak but I wonder if you have this
would be second now third and because
you talk to people who knew them
relatives did any more of this kind it
seems like a lot of it was you know very
very closeted and and we never heard
much common right well this isn't a
repeat the question the question is did
anyone in the ledge party ever speak
about it that it's very strange that a
conspiracy someone would not speak and
this is an unspeakable thing as I said
in my introduction and my friend bill
Kinney told me that when he was a little
boy his mother admonished him never to
ask about the Leo Frank case that said
one of the men who was muscle on the
Lynch party a guy named Luther Burton he
felt horrible about his role and late in
his life he went to a judge here in Cobb
County Jim Manning and he unburdened
himself to judge Manning and
judge Manning unburdened himself to bill
Kenny so bill Kenny whose own uncle was
in the ledger Artie heard the truth of
this from someone who heard it from a
lynch party member and while bill Kenney
was very played his cards close to this
mess with me initially by the time my
book was done he told me everything that
Judge Manning had told him yes sir yes
Steve if you will you please speak some
more about William Smith in particular
the note it was up there that he wrote
on his deathbed is in the previous slide
right there William Smith is the unsung
hero of the Frank case he represented
Jim Connelly he represented him very
well he was from Augusta William Smith
he was an early advocate of really equal
rights for blacks as much as anyone
could be an advocate of that a hundred
years ago and he thought that Frank's
powerful lawyers were going to railroad
Conley and so he defended Conley at the
trial got him off on a misdemeanor
charge but as the case developed he
began to think that Jim Connelly might
have done it he kept catching Jim calmly
and wise so he did this exhaustive study
of all of Jim Connolly's written and
spoken utterances he did it with his
wife who would become a schoolteacher
they did it at their kitchen table at
their little home in Weston and Atlanta
and by the time he was done with his
study he believed that Leo Frank was
innocent and Jim Conley was the guilty
party and he ultimately took the results
of his study to the newspapers there
were huge front page headlines his life
was threatened his legal practice was
destroyed in Atlanta he washed up in New
York a couple years later working as a
security guard at a shipyard in Brooklyn
it was during World War one and there
was a lot of fear of infiltration by
German spies and you know not until five
or six years later did he get his law
practice back and as a lawyer in New
York he
ultimately made a little money and
bought some property up in Lumpkin
County North of Dahlonega and was going
to start a school for poor kids and he
didn't live to see his dream he died of
Lou Gehrig's disease at Crawford long
hospital and Lou Gehrig's disease
if any of you sadly had experience with
it it robs you of your vocal powers
ultimately and his kids took him to the
hospital at Crawford long and they put
him in an oxygen tent and he wrote this
series of notes to his kids and most of
them were about insurance policies and
unfinished business and stuff to do for
Mom and at the last myth gathered
himself and you can see through the note
it's on the back of the prescription pad
and he wrote in articles of death I
believe in the innocence and good
character of Leland Frank and then it's
sign was sort of a flourish and it's a
Hollywood tragedy he dies shortly
thereafter but the note is both a
personal statement of conscience but
because of the legal construct he's
making a deathbed statement that he
hopes someday will be heard in some
larger court and and he was Gymkhana
Lee's lawyer he was Gymkhana Lee's
lawyer and you know part of the reason
he destroyed his law practice is he
other lawyers in Atlanta thought that he
had you know betrayed client lawyer
confidentiality he felt his
understanding of the law was that he
hadn't that his opinions were based on
nothing Jim Conley had said that based
on his own research he also felt the
double jeopardy statute in Georgia was
such that Jim Connelly could never be
tried for Mary Fagin's murder but you
know that's that's all legal talk but
it's a very brave note it's very moving
yes sir
marry Figgins family was not fluent as I
understand it
I wonder who who paid for that very
elaborate marker they at her gravesite
IV not the question is who paid for the
beautiful tombstone at Mary Phagan his
gravesite there's both the stone and
then there's a flat stone that has a
gorgeous poem engraved into it about the
tears of Georgia and how Mary Phagan his
death elicited these tears and it was
paid for by the either the United
Daughters of the Confederacy or the
confederate veterans of the of war sol
is a fund was taken up and there's a you
know on the tombstone the credit is
engraved I'm blanking out where there
was the UDC or the actual veterans but
they paid for it
we're given two alternative explanations
about the case
some believe Leo Frank did it minority a
majority believe that Jim Connelly did
it have you considered a third
possibility that is that knowing what we
know about Leo Frank that he might have
attacked Mary Phagan knocked you
unconscious and then Connally finished
the deed in the basement I have thought
about that I've thought that that's a
very plausible view I don't know how
many in the audience have read Tom Wolfe
you repeat the question is is there a
third alternative you know right now we
look at the Mary Phagan murder as a Leo
Frank did it or Jim Connelly did it but
is there an alternative explanation that
maybe Leo Frank had some kind of
assignation with Mary Phagan it got out
of hand it didn't go the way he wanted
Jim Connelly came in to take care of it
and she ended up dead that they both had
some culpability and there are even
other possibilities there were two or
three other people floating through the
factory on that day and I bring the
investigations into them in the early
chapters of my book but Leo Franks if
anyone's read the novel bonfire of the
vanities by Tom Wolfe it's a you know
fabulous novel about stemming from a
misunderstanding of a crime in New York
City and the protagonist comes home from
a party and a black guy has been
sideswiped by his fancy car and he says
he didn't have anything to do with it
and he didn't have anything to do with
it his mistress was driving the car so
he's taking the fall for her and so you
know who's to know about human behavior
I can't really judge we don't have the
information but it's a valid theory yes
I have been reading the last few days
it's called the truth of the LIA Frank's
case and it was written I think a year
and a half after the case that happened
and it talked a lot about the fairness
and the unfairness of the actual trial
I'd like to hear your opinion on that
the trial was a disaster from a legal
point of view there was applause in the
courtroom when the prosecution scored
points so right there you had a sense of
the way the gallery was going the
cross-examination of Jim Connelly during
his testimony was horrible malfeasance
really legal malfeasance by Frank's
lawyers Conley introduced a number of
instances of Leo Frank's supposed
philandering in the factory using the
factory as a place to complete his tryst
and the defense then cross-examined you
know they didn't challenge it though all
of that should have been irrelevant it
was all irrelevant Frank was on trial
for murder not for his personal sexual
behavior but the defense let it go
because the defense very arrogantly
believed that it could knock down this
shiftless black man that the prosecution
had propped up as its lead witness the
you know Hugh Dorsey he did introduce as
I said you know these statements about
how much money Frank had and you know
kept using the word
capitalist Oh Frank's mother testified
about their financial affairs and where
they had their money out and Dorsey
would say oh so your husband doesn't
work no he doesn't work so he's a
capitalist well no he's got some money
that he's investing I was so he's a
capitalist as if that's a bad thing but
it meant that Leo Frank likes American
Jews controlled the capital investment
and the poor working girl Mary Phagan so
that that was unfair on Dorothy's part
but it was a the trial could never
happen again
I don't think yes sir could you comment
on the testimony that Alonso man gave in
his video deposition the fact that he
was on the stand and those issues never
arose and the actual ruling of the
posthumous pardon with respect to the
fairness of the trial Alonso man the
question is what about Alonso a man's
testimony at the trial and what bearing
does that have and then 75 years later
when he came forth in the posthumous
pardon application was put out what
merit did his story have done Alonso he
was a shy fourteen year old his
testimony at the trial was very brief
one of the newspapers even commented on
what an unimpressive or nervous young
man he was and then 75 years later he
comes forth to say that on the day of
Mary Figgins murder he'd worked at the
office up until about noon helping Leo
Frank he'd gone out he got a block or so
from the office realized he'd forgotten
something ran back to the factory burst
into the lobby insult Jim calmly holding
Mary Fagin's body in the lobby and that
Conley wagged a finger at him and said
if you tell anybody I'll kill you and
Alonso ran out and told his parents and
his parents urged him not to get
involved that part of his story bothers
me a little bit when I wrote my ass for
article I leaned very heavily on Alonso
story in my book Alonso only appears at
the end because you know this is inside
baseball but in the evidence against Leo
Frank a lot of it turns on whether the
elevator was used to transport Mary
Fagin's body from the alleged murder
site on the second floor of the factory
where Frank had his office to the
basement whether where the body was
found
or whether and the other views suggest
Connelly killed her
whether Connelly struck her in the lobby
and dumped her body through a little
hole in the edge of the lobby into the
basement where a ladder ran down to the
lobby well there was some odiferous
evidence that played into the case from
the start there was feces deposited at
the bottom of the elevator shaft
and the feces was still fresh on the day
Mary Fagin's body was found and at the
trial Jim Connolly said he had defecated
in the factory elevator shaft and this
in decorous evidence became known as the
[ __ ] in the shaft and there was a great
debate about it at the trial and the
reason it's interesting and I'll get to
the why I'm telling you in relation to
Alonso is if the feces was still fresh
in the factory on the Sunday morning the
body was found the elevator was never
used because the elevator touched bottom
of that elevator shaft every time so
that gave the lie to jim Connolly's
testimony the elevator was never used
the body went in the basement through
this tiny hole at the edge of the lobby
and you know falsus in uno
falsus UNAM novices lawyers say false in
the particular false and everything that
one like shows that comley's entire tale
was a fabrication
Alonzo's story just buttresses what the
[ __ ] in the shaft already advances
Alonso didn't cast any new light on the
tale Alonso was just a remarkably vivid
mechanism for getting us interested
again in a story that most of us had
forgotten what about the pardon itself
had never spoke to innocence
well I when I wrote my story for eschar
I self the Boardman part of Gordon Board
of Pardons and Paroles had erred in not
granting Leo Frank a posthumous pardon
but by the time I was finished with my
book and done all this research I
thought the board made the correct
decision the correct decision and saying
we did not protect Leo Frank's
constitutional rights and essentially we
apologize I didn't think as the lawyers
would argue that there was sufficient
probative evidence to give Leo Frank a
blanket exoneration I mean if you start
overturning convictions based on the
memories of 85 year old witnesses 70
some years after the fact that would
call all verdicts into question and you
know so I leave it as a mystery I mean I
make the case strongly in my book that
Leo Frank was innocent but I'm
ultimately not sure I got a positive
review in the Los Angeles Times by the
Pulitzer prize-winning historian David
Garrow who won the Pulitzer for this
biography of Martin Luther King and he
accused me of moral cowardice in this
otherwise positive review for not
slamming the door on this subject and
you know I responded in conversation
that I'm not omniscient I just don't
know
yes hi having been born and raised in
the South I've actually only heard of
the lynching of Leo Frank
in a southern context and I was actually
wondering how does the rest of America
see this case as part of the southern
identity this was a huge national story
this was one of the three or four trials
of the century along with the Lindbergh
baby and the Sam Sheppard case in
Cleveland and probably the OJ case but
this touched on deeper issues and any of
those cases did those cases were all
sensational and fascinating but this
touched on the third rail of race and
ethnicity and class and you know those
are the live wires that are down there
and the American infrastructure and when
you tease one out they're going to be
Sparks and people are going to get
burned and you know I when Leo Frank is
limps the response from the national
press was devastating
I think the Chicago Tribune said that
the south is far from civilized until
fresh blood is introduced it will remain
a land of savages
there were editorial cartoons in the New
York papers you know showing caricature
in the south is beasts and this was a
beastly thing this is a so it it
cemented the view of of an irrational
violent prone people and you know
terrified American Jews America is
supposed to be he's a great exception
for the Jewish people this is a land
without religious prejudice this is a
land of opportunity for all in this case
gave the light of that the lucky thing
for the south is that Leo Frank was
lynched and within about six months the
Lusitania had already been sunken within
about 6 months we were into World War
one and and the world for God
does that answer your question I mean
it's it's a it's a fabulous subject I
mean you can look at it through a lens
of religion or race or gender you know
Mary Fagin's was a victimized child
laborer I mean she's part of this to it
it's a very volatile case thank you
Steve you and I talked about this a
little bit and that it's it's the South
has to come to terms with the
Confederacy and Confederate iconography
and has to come to terms with Jim Jim
Crow and lynching and the dis case
occupies some special place within all
of that somehow this case is just weird
this case touches a bunch of you know it
goes against the grain on many levels of
white man convicted on a black man's
testimony the and you know to the
victors went the spoils Tom Watson was
elected the United States Senate
Theodore C was elected governor of
Georgia but again I say it goes against
the grain when Hugh Dorsey was governor
of Georgia he did a extensive study on
lynching in Georgia and tried to get
through the legislature a law that would
allow State Police to respond in any hot
spot where he thought a lynching or
where they saw the lynching might occur
and that sort of ruined his career and
he made another very powerful pro-black
decision as a Superior Court judge in
the Alonzo Herndon case which is a
famous person in that case in the 1930s
hernán was a black guy accused of
distributing seditious communist
literature on the steps of the post
office in downtown Atlanta and Dorsey
found in favor of Herndon so these these
were not all black and white yes sir
thank you for your presentation thank
you
was there anything unique about Marietta
in that the lynching party originated
from Marietta as opposed to it
originating in some other area of
Atlanta repeat the question is what made
Mary out of the unique source of the
lynch party why did it come from here
well Mary Hagen
while born in Alabama grew up in
Marietta and her home her childhood home
was in the Sardis section which was
within sight of the lynching site so the
first news of the lynching was a phone
call to the sheriff's office in Marietta
it was come quick Leo Frank hanging
retribution so this was a this is a
local girl and the elders of this
community you know lynching was a
symbolic act lynching was an act of
terrorism and it was usually aimed at
blacks and it was usually aimed at the
most vulnerable and primal part of black
men their sexuality and here it left the
track and went after a Jewish lynching
victim essentially for the same reason
good evening Steve hey Mike
welcome home Thanks what strikes me is
remarkable about the Leo Frank trial was
the fact that Frank was convicted by an
all-male jury of white men obviously it
was not a representative drawn from a
representative cross-section of the
community assuming that there were
plenty of women around do you have any
feel for what the verdict might have
been if women had been on the jury I
don't know women couldn't serve on the
jury in 1913 because they couldn't vote
so they weren't on the jury list and
there's but if your question is germane
there was an incredible woman in Atlanta
in the 1920s named Jesse Daniel Eames
and she's a subject of a great book by a
University of North Carolina historian
it's called revolt against chivalry and
Jesse Daniel Eames posited that lynching
was a grotesque act of chivalry and not
until women got the vote and not until
women were able to say you know we're
capable of fending for ourselves with
lynching end and this book revolt
against chivalry won a lot of big awards
and had there
women had women been empowered to use
the currently fashionable verb it might
have gone a little differently it's
funny though blacks were on the juror
list and to give you a sense of the way
Frank's lawyers handled this every JAC
every black who got you know into the
the pool Frank's lawyers would use a
strike on him because they didn't want a
black juror that wouldn't work today so
it did then just a brief follow-up
question it was an absolutely daunting
task that you undertook to write this
book and I think it was awesome well
thank you and I wonder you know I know
you had so much ground to cover but I
wonder if you had any opportunity to
look into any of the backgrounds of the
jurors and if any of the people you
talked to gave you any hint at all that
there may have been any improper conduct
yeah well that in the second part of the
book the defense makes what's known as
an extraordinary motion for a new trial
and much of that is based on
investigation that the defense made into
juror conduct and you know they found
they tried to make a case that three or
four of the jurors were anti-semitic or
went on if they weren't anti-semitic
they went on the jury having expressed
their belief in Frank's guilt and it
didn't fought but that was part of the
appellate argument at some stage thanks
thank you
I really I really don't have a question
I have a quick comment on behalf of the
family of Lucille Frank and Leo Frank I
want to thank you Steve for all of the
years that you've spent in putting these
facts together where everyone can read
and history can be presented also I'd
like to thank the Georgia Historical
Society and all of the others that have
helped put together this fine program
tonight for this event well thank you
thank you
thank you thank you hey Otto
eighth-graders Georgia history every
year and I get to teach the whole Leo
Frank story including the elevator shaft
although I don't usually colorful I
probably great new straight babe and
then we go to lunch and they enjoy that
but um what's the biggest takeaway that
I can did you think an eighth-grade
student can take away from this case and
when my students from East Hall in Hall
County get to go to Atlanta for some of
them it's the first time and they see
that statue of Tom Watson outside the
Capitol and they're saying miss Farr
what is going on why is he still there
we don't understand what are some of the
lessons that you think we can take away
from this case that I can give to my
students to my kids I think most y'all
heard that but she's an eighth grade
teacher in Hall County and she wants to
know what lessons she can give to her
students based on this awful tale and
you know I think there are life lessons
about being fair being honest not
jumping to conclusions being brave being
willing to stand up against a crowd you
know there are many areas that of
citizenship stories of citizenship to
come out of this as for the statute of
Tom Watson I have a funny view about
that I was kind of sorry they moved it
and here's why one of the great books
about the civil rights movement is
called my soul is rested by Howell
Raines is an oral history of the civil
rights movement how was a political
reporter for the Constitution back in
the 70s he went on to be the editor of
the New York Times when he was at the
Constitution he had a little office in
the State Capitol it looked out on the
Statue of Tom Watson and he never he
looked at it every day and he just
basically kept asking himself what
happened what happened to this guy
because Tom Watson started out as a
liberal and Tom Watson would have black
preachers on the stump with him when he
was campaigning in the 1890s and he had
this incredible line he would use and
this is why he's so terrified elites in
Atlanta
he would tell racially mixed audiences
he would say you are kept apart so you
may be separately fleeced he would say
your interest for black men and your
interest Porter farming white cracker
are the same and that terrified
Atlanta's elite and then something
turned in Tom Watson and it all went
wrong anyway how wrote about the civil
rights movement in this great book and
he starts his book by talking about
seeing the statue of Tom Watson out of
his office and he's looking at it every
day and he's puzzling over what this
means when the book is relatively new
what does it mean in an age when we have
a black homecoming queen at the
University of Alabama of which I guess
was news the year how was writing and so
he used it as a jumping-off point and my
conclusion is that history should not be
effaced or erased
there are many difficult parts of
history and our job is not to impose our
agenda on it our job is to learn what it
has to tell us we're here to be
receptive listeners and to try not to
repeat the mistakes they made and if you
erase all the evidence then where does
the discussion start so but that's a
difficult point to make because these
are and I'm not a purist about it when I
was at the University of Georgia Roger
danced a great band director of the
Redcoat marching band he'd already
stopped the playing a Dixie at home
football games and I was really grateful
to him for that I thought that was a
brave decision and because it's a
beautiful song but it just mostly was
used to get people who didn't care about
the game worked up about stuff that had
nothing to do with football so you know
I'm not a I don't believe in in waving
the Confederate flag but I do believe
that some of these monuments are
important starting points for honest
conversation and if we take them all
down what are we going to talk about I
think you can also point out and ask
them if they know the story of Tom
Watson's involvement in this case ask
them to look at that Monument and
identify anything on there that had
anything about his involvement people
complained about historical revisionism
now I always point out the Tom Watson
statue is a how-to kit in political
revision or historical revisionism
because the stuff it's on there very
selectively chosen I mean that's how
monuments are put together and I think
that it's a during the difference
between monument and history I think
yeah it's a great jumping-off point and
your kids this book by C Vann Woodward I
mentioned Tom Watson of Aaron Revell it
can be read by fairly young person it's
a beautifully written book and it starts
off when Tom Watson was a little boy
living in Thompson he was going to
Augusta to see the trains bring back the
dead and wounded Confederate soldiers in
the late part of the war and you know he
was he lived in a different world he was
shaped by stuff that is hard for us to
comprehend sleep I got we got time for
like two more questions all right
Tim well we have two more questions this
is real quick you spoke earlier about
people that helped you along your
investigation everything else in your
enquiries did you ever come across
anybody that stonewalled you or coerced
you to go a different route or you know
kind of leave such a touchy sensitive
subject alone the question is whose
stonewalled me well the children of some
of the Lynch party members stonewalled
me this fellow George Morris I mentioned
a while ago he knew exactly what
happened and he just shoved my inquiries
aside funny thing people in Marietta
were much more open about this as a rule
than members of Atlanta's Jewish
community who had lived through it now
maybe it's not so funny this was a
psychic and political and horrific blow
to the communal psyche of Atlanta's Jews
and they dealt with it by repressing it
it was you know if you believe in
Freudian analysis this was an instance
of mass repression they couldn't talk
about the Frank lynching
mariette ins didn't have so much to lose
they just had something they would
increasingly grow a shamed about that
they didn't want to speak of although
this one is in my book
Dorothy Haney Smith this line to me sums
up how Marietta felt about it then it's
certainly not now but Dorothy said daddy
was not proud but he was not ashamed and
I thought that was the voice of the
lunch party yes sir I was fascinated by
your stories from your interviews and
we've all witnessed many injustice Azur
wrongdoings
in our own lives and too often people
don't do anything about and so when I
heard the comment earlier about messages
for the children one for us older folks
might be the words we never want to hear
grandad why didn't you yeah that's a the
question is as we get older and we learn
about people who went along and when we
ask ourselves when did we go along when
we should have stood up what's going to
be like when our grandchildren or young
people say well why didn't you stand up
and I think you know there are all sorts
of Maxim's about how you lead your life
that you'll be what you'll be sorry
about is not what you did what you
didn't do and I think there's some truth
to that I also think you'll be sorry if
if you didn't stand up and did you know
there are ways little ways each of us
everyday doesn't stand up we're all
failed but you know maybe this nice way
to end that it's getting up again when
you didn't stand up and trying to stand
up the next time that's that's a good
thing to do so thank you all thank you
Steve thank you
[Music]